we crowned our very first VCT game
changers champions in Berlin and I was
there to watch every single second of it
G2 goes and are your Champions but the
event didn't end without any sort of
drama so let's talk about it
yeah we're going to be talking about the
game changers championship in Berlin and
I was there all thanks to our babes over
at Elgato be sure to check out their
brand new stream deck plus this bad boy
has knobs you can turn to adjust many
different things a touch screen and the
classic macro keys to help you in
whatever way you need to be helped we
made a YouTube stars that talks all
about the stream deck plus and how can
help you make content on the go go check
it out and get yours using the link
below I'm back on donat me baby and I
miss all of you so so so much but mama
has been busy I just got back from
Berlin from the vcg game changers
championship and oh boy we saw clutches
we saw fun walkouts we even saw ruling
that some believe affected the Grand
Final so buckle up baby for those of you
who don't know valorent game changers is
a competitive circuit within the Valor
Esports ecosystem that aims to create
quote New Opportunities and exposure for
women and other marginalized genders
within Valor and Esports the VCT Game
Changer circuit has been happening for a
while now domestically but teams haven't
met internationally so there's a lot of
excitement surrounding this event being
game changer's First International
Tournament featuring eight of the
world's best teams coming into this
tournament there was a lot of Buzz
surrounding Cloud9 white The Undefeated
Titans of n a they were the favorites to
win it all and they had a pretty good
first match after winning that they came
face to face with the titans of EMA G2
goes in this was a match that people
were expecting to see as the grand
finals the fact that was happening so
early was a huge deal a lot of people
thought this was going to be the best
most exciting match of the tournament
and it was something else in the
dimensional drift on top of that to get
all that information Alexis Elise gets
the kill off the glass but the push out
there's no time Jimmy comes out to get
the last two kills the G2 wins the
series well there was the yoruan Pearl
or just nerves C9 white found themselves
having to crawl through the lower
bracket that was the same case for
Shopify Rebellion Na's other
representative these two teams are
rivals in N A Cloud9 white has beaten
them every single time except once and
this time they met in the lower bracket
on the grandest stage of them all so the
battle to represent North America went
down and flower fall on top of the a
Tower every release out on this that's
gonna be it Shopify Rebellion eliminate
Cloud9 white for the VCT game changers
championship and that's gonna feel so
good look how much it means to them to
beat them after getting beat online all
the time for the last two years finally
on land Shopify Rebellion defied a lot
of expectations and sent Cloud9 white
home which in and of itself is an insane
achievement but their work wasn't done
that day they had to face the best of
Brazil team liquid once again after
already facing and losing to them in the
upper bracket semi-final Shopify
Rebellion beat Team Liquid and secured
their spot in the grand finals doing
what many would consider an impossible
task to get down two Titans in one day
Shopify Rebellion made it to the Grand
finals and spectacular convincing
fashion proving many doubters wrong but
their biggest obstacle would not be
facing G2 goes in no you see you
witnessed a moment earlier on a single
decision that would impact the entire
Grand Final and Loom over it like a dark
cloud did you catch it if you didn't
that's okay let's rewind all the time
for the last two years finally on land
in case it isn't clear Shopify
rebellion's coach Rob Wiz flipped the
bird to Xenon white after beating them
later he would tweet Nothing in life
could bring me more pleasure than
eliminating those talkers 2-1 against
Cloud9 white and we move on to lower
finals gfg he walked it back a bit later
saying Heat of the Moment got the best
of me sorry endured a lot this year and
emotions took over fell down to their
level for a second all good now I'm
going to set the scene of how I found
out what happened next it's a chilly
night in Berlin in fact that day I had
to buy a new coat and scarf I even
bought a new perfume I'd get back to my
hotel I fall asleep but I wake up in the
middle of the night because I just have
trouble sleeping and I decide I'm gonna
open Twitter and see what people are
talking about and to see people are
talking about something and I'm like huh
everyone's saying something what could
it be it is a competitive ruling from
riot games because those bring absolute
joy and no problems because of the
offensive gesture Rob whiz was fined and
suspended from the grand finals
therefore he would not be able to be
with his team if we had more time I wish
I could show you every single reaction
from Pros to commentators to fans about
this decision but if I may paraphrase
for you it was a collective um what the
Benita from Shopify responded to
the decision by saying just want to say
that we've been getting talked for
months in game they type in all chat and
out of game people also questioned the
competitive Integrity of the suspension
since Rob Woods was suspended for a
match instead of only be given a warning
for it appeared to be his first offense
I asked all of you on Twitter and most
of you said that a fine and a warning
would have warranted enough punishment
that suspending Rob wiz was going too
far and listen hi Riot it's Liz I know
we are all in different time zones and
different slack channels but at least
communicate with your highlights team to
not include you did in the post-match
highlights reel but that was that there
was no change to the ruling and we had a
grand finals to watch Shopify Rebellion
had their assistant coach Finn step in
against the fight to G2 goes in we also
got some clarification from the global
head of Valor Esports leopharia the next
day about the decision to suspend Rob
was uh we had some challenges and I want
to dress directly the ruling yeah that
um we applied to the coach of Shopify
rebellion and um the time is just very
unfortunate right to have a coach not be
able to be on stage with a team when the
stakes are high the reality is whenever
there is a situation like this that
requires a ruling we look at all the
factors involving the situation of
course fans saw what happened on stage
but we look at the whole picture what
happened before that um
event what happened after on Backstage
and then would make a decision and it's
really about applying the rules and
being fair and not choosing when
applying the rules versus not regardless
of all that the game still had to be
played not to Shopify Rebellion took the
first two maps G2 goes and were forced
to do something that is literally never
happened at an International ballerin
Event before they reverse swept shot
fire rebellion and became your inaugural
game changers Champions G2 goes and may
have won the trophy but I want to talk
about the incredible win for the scene
that we had this Championship was
Monumental a space for marginalized
genders to compete at the highest level
doesn't exist really very few spaces are
like this viewership of this event
became according to Esports charts the
most watched female tournament in the
history of Esports so many people met
teams like fennel Hotel lava for example
for the first time who were literally
together for only a month before they
competed here places like this are not
just important for marginalized genders
but for the Esports scene as a whole
because the entire scene cannot continue
to grow and Thrive without everyone
being given a place to shine Line Game
Changers is just the beginning
but don't forget to get your stream deck
Plus in the description below uh it's
great it's right here you can see it uh
that sign over there made it onto the
broadcast it's the most list thing I've
ever done in my life it's it's uh it's
Liz Centric if you will I I could have
made a funny sign but I just made me
complaining so
hope you're proud mom